You know,
recover in between trips.
Um,
there isn't this pressure to be where people are getting their heads blown off
every single time.
In the last film I did was about Yemen and we spent a week on the front lines
with the various fighting groups and got the usual crazy fighting footage.
But the powerful staff was a woman who had her leg blown off by an airstrike in
an IDP camp and a miserable IDP camp where the Saudis Nimrod,
he's a claiming lit,
providing people with everything they need.
And then at the end,
a child malnutrition clinic right on the front line where a nurse just just
begged all parties to end this war.
And she was,
she was literally on the front line surrounded by a minefield,
couldn't get doctors,
couldn't get supplies at a few dozen kids in this clinic that she was just
managing to keep alive.
You know,
these wailing and Macy babies with their rib cages,
caged,
caved in.
Um,
and you know,
the reason you do this or to cover the effects of war,
it's not to get crazy for Tj of explosions and shoot outs.
It's the effect of war on civilians.
So maybe the answer is to do that and not feel this pressure to,
to,
to just get the crazy fighting footage all the time.
In our country,
Yemen is in many ways mostly synonymous for drone attacks.
Drone strikes is when we think about Yemen,
we think about the drone strikes that we hear about on wedding parties.
The accident or the,
the,
the number of people that are accidentally killed a civilian casualty rate is
some preposterous number.
Yeah.
I mean,
no one knows because you can't check out most of these areas,
but it's in the tens of thousands at least.
And it's,
the percentage is also preposterous.
It's far more than 50%.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's airstrikes.
Yeah.
So it used to be us drone strikes on,
on al Qaeda that's mix now at Saudi Mrr,
t airstrikes and um,
with,
with us assistance.
I mean,
we were until recently refueling the plane,
supplying the plane,
supplying the weapons.
But yeah,
they've hit weddings,
funerals,
that,
schools,
hospitals.
Um,
and I don't think that's,
that's by accident.
I think they're taking an approach to Yemen that,
that we need to crush the opposition.
I'm not take out the military leaders and you can't,
there's no movement in history that's been crushed by force that never works.
Choose Christ.
When you're over there,
what does it feel like in Yemen as opposed to Afghanistan or other places?
Um,
Yemen,
the actual fighting is much more low intensity.
It's fairly small groups of guys at some distance just lobbing shells,
each other.
And there's,
you know,
there's snipers and there are gunfights but it's not as big scalers as Iraq or
Afghanistan.
But there were a regular air strikes that are killing civilians.
Um,
and while the two sides are fighting this,
this slow and bloody war,
um,
the infrastructure is being destroyed and the civilians are unable to get basic
food and medicine.
That,
that's the really shocking thing there.
And also,
I mean,
I knew that,
that the coalition is,
it's called,
you know,
the,
the fighting groups backed by a Saudi Arabia and UAE were American backed.
But you see American stuff everywhere.
I mean,
m wraps,
you know,
these million dollar bombproof trucks.
I've only ever seen American soldiers and marines driving in Iraq and
Afghanistan.
You see them everywhere there.
Um,
and that's a real surprise to see that.
Wow.
How did Yemen become this area that's so synonymous with drone strikes?
Like why did we approach Yemen differently than any other part of the world in
terms of the,
the,
the allocation of drone strikes there in terms of numbers?
I don't know.
I mean,
I think for a while the only thing the US was doing in Yemen was drone strikes
against al Qaeda.
Um,
but I don't know if there had been more drone strikes in Yemen than,
than elsewhere.
I mean that's where we killed an American citizen,
right.
That which got lots of headlines,
right on purpose with no trial.
They just sued to say we'll do it was because he,
uh,
joined isis.
Is that what it was for out?
Cause yeah,
it was a,
was a very well known and popular,
um,
you know,
uh,
online presence and rallying people to,
to,
to fight.
But the air strikes in,
in,
in Yemen,
uh,
um,
you know,
and,
and you know,
with,
with us weapons are that,
that's,
that that's what's really killing people and,
and meeting that people can't get,
get food and aid there because you just can't move things around there.
Um,
whatever came out of that guy getting killed,
they,
they basically,
no one was punished for it.
I mean,
he's an American citizen.
He was,
I mean,
if it was in America,
if somehow or another this guy was in the suburbs of Chicago and they launched a
jar,
a drone strike on them,
it would be front page news and it'd be a real issue.
But the fact it was in Yemen,
I mean,
again,
the legacy of Iraq and Afghanistan is that now we're killing guys like him with
drone strikes or special forces raids here and there.
And it's happening almost in secret.
And no one's saying this appears to be illegal.
I mean,
some people are,
you know,
you can,
which media outlets you can go to to read about this.
But I think most people are thinking if that's,
if that's the alternative to invasion.
Yeah.
And trillions of dollars and American soldiers coming back with no legs for a
wall.
We don't understand Brian.
I think a lot of people are willing to accept it.
I don't agree with it.
But that seems to be what's happening now.
No,
I think you're right.
Um,
the,
the other thing about that is with a lot of these,
even though it does seem to be illegal,
people sort of shrug their shoulders and then no one pursues it and then it just
kind of goes away.
Yeah.
But there's some stories that for whatever reason,
like Jamal Shogi did not go away and still still out there.
Like it was so egregious and so crazy that this guy walks into the embassy and
just never comes out.
And they're like,
I don't know what happened.
And then slowly you start getting a different story.
And then apparently there's leaked,
there's audio and perhaps even video of his murder that ordered,
by the way,
by someone who was hanging out with Jared Krishna afterwards,
um,
with apparently no mention of,
of,
of what happened.